[Music]
in previous videos you have seen us
setting up the places where we work eat
cook and come together
but we never really showed you how we
sleep it's mainly centered around vans
let me show you a few different forms
and shapes
welcome to a new project camp update
let's go straight to the first van
this is msvan
hello welcome do you want to see my van
i don't have a house this this van is my
house at the moment
and
i pretty like it
i picked this fan because
i heard that it's a real workhorse
also the dimensions are are good because
you can stand in it so it doesn't feel
that too small
and it really feels like
my room
like my tiny house
this is the kitchen
i like to have
a lot of space so i make this
because i don't like it if there's like
this less
space to work
you can lock it
it's just a normal stove
not for campers or whatever but
it's not that heavy and i liked it the
sink
with the tap
it's working with a pump so you will
hear it a little bit but i don't mind
kitchen closets a bit messy right now
but there's enough space for all the
herbs oil
the water of the sink
right now goes directly to
the land so i only use
just my homemade soap
but i also made a tank underneath so
that's one thing that's also under
construction a big fridge with a freezer
just a normal fridge but it was way
cheaper because i have a converter i can
use this it takes less energy and it has
a freezer so a lot of space and a
freezer that's what you want
this is the isolation i used i isolate
all the van i can stand in the sun it
will be warm but if i open the two doors
it's totally fine and this part is where
i have my clothes
this one broke already
i need to fix that too
this is uh yeah the best mattress i ever
had
these are extra closets so
laundry
martinis
audio stuff
my stuff
very very secrets
vip
bucket p bucket
so sometimes it happens that you can't
pee outside because you're in the middle
of the city or something
so i have this i can take it out pee in
there
and
put it back if i need to drive
so i have those two blocks
so it's it locked so it doesn't fall
over
i can take this out
and there we have the toilet paper
a few windows but they're a bit small
and a bit hidden because i like to be a
bit hidden though people don't see that
it is really a camper van this is my
favorite part of the van
it's the
window of an old wooden sailing ship
i really like it too
i don't know
i this is just
my proud i think
this is the back of the van
where i
keep all my machines
they are they need to be safe because
this is my my work
so you can go
through
the you can't pick them from the front
you need to open these doors and i have
an extra lock
at the back so if i leave the van
i double lock it
to be sure that i still have my machines
hey
it's pretty backspace i can have
two rows of these boxes
and they are exactly the same
measurement as these boxes where i have
the rest of my tools
then we have this table
great
[Applause]
yeah it's nice if i can work on it but i
didn't really do that yet
water and gas
so it's 22 liters it's not
a lot it makes you
be more aware of
how you use the water in the kitchen
yeah and the gas bottle you've seen it's
not
not a big one but it's enough i'm
traveling now for four months and
yeah
it's still there so i have those three
big batteries it's like 300 ampere
and a big
solar panel on top of the van it gives
me enough power for everything this is
martin's surfboard
it's too ugly to go inside but i gave it
to him so i can't i can say that
so i hope you enjoyed the van
and
yeah
see you next
time this is the van where adrian and i
live
hey welcome to our van and bedroom i
want to show you a bit what we have
inside but first take out your shoes
you spend a lot of time in the building
of this floor
we builded our all ourselves we made a
big fort in the insulation part of the
van it's quite important for it
so we can keep it warm in winter and
cold in summer the van itself i bought
it in 2018 when i was in the netherlands
it's a vehicle from the 90s it's an old
piece of metal but super strong motor i
hope it's gonna last more than me
this is our bedroom we have a
big bed with a nice mattress
we also have our bookshelf we have some
electricity plug here to charge our
phones or the computer
lights for reading
but what makes it special
is that we can
fully
slide it
in order to have a big space in the back
to transport machines materials
bikes whatever we want so we have a
kitchen with two stoves
ready for cooking it's quite easy to
cook food with it we have a little oven
too
another
of the few things that we bought new in
the van
that we are really happy with it
then we have our simple water system
it's just a jerry can of 20 liters with
a top and a simple sink
it's cool because when you have like
this amount of water you're really
conscious of the amount of the water you
consume you really see how the water is
going down so you don't use much the van
is powered by solar panels on the top
and then it goes to the simple regulator
and then we build this box with all the
fuses and we also have an inverter to be
able to have
220 energy in the van
so here we have a foldable table
all this wood is fun it's coming from
the neighbor's named oven just took it
re-ensemble it make it in our shape and
use it again
a great big upgrade on this van that we
made recently let's install this
big window
where we can see the rain from the
inside
it opens completely and we also have
mosquito nets
or a blind when we don't want lightning
i'm a coffee lover so we have big coffee
machine there in the kitchen but i also
have my own collection here
i also have
this one that we got
in belgrade a couple of years ago to
make another kind of coffee here is
where we sit to drink these coffees
usually
[Music]
we have this sliding table under the bed
to
keep
big space in the van in general but be
able to
have dinner have a chat work a bit
here we have also a bit more storage
space where we have still more books a
bit more space in this
it's our dry toilet
but
maybe i don't show you do this now
and under the bed is where we keep all
our clothes
we share two crates for me
two crates for julie and there we have
almost all our clothes
all recycled wood
it's all tropical wood really nice
finishing that gives you this feeling of
being in a boat a bit all these lines
that go from the front to the back gives
you this spacious feeling now we go to
the back
[Music]
portable shower made with an old jerry
can you connect it to the 12 volt plugs
we showed you before
and then we will have an
outdoor shower precious plastic
injection machine build according to
that
fully functional just in case there's
some plastic to recycle around
thanks for visiting and now i'm gonna
keep on reading my book
thank you and see you
[Music]
and here we have dave's fan
hey
welcome to my van my house
originally i built the van
because i knew we would start project
camp so living close to a community that
has facilities like your shower your
kitchen
chill area so the van is more like your
bathroom
so one of the main reasons of getting
this van is that i'm kind of a tall
dutch guy and i can stand in here
which i thought if this is going to be
my house i want to make sure i can stand
in it
here's a very small basic kitchen simple
stove to put on because most of the time
i don't really cook here
because we have shark meals in the camp
so this is more every now and then for a
weekend if you want to take some time
alone
cut a few cooking spices not much mainly
quite boss tea and cacao that's what i
eat some cleaning things for my ear
things like the water system it's just a
jerry can with gravity so no complex
pumps and stuff it's empty filled jerry
can and you're good to go
got a smile sink here that just flushes
down outwards
just on the ground
so no complex additional tanks and this
kind of stuff under the sink i have
a very
dirty solar setup usb charger but it has
enough wattage to also charge your
laptop so now i would use bc so i rarely
use the inverter i like it a lot so
here's the bat it's a fixed bat so you
can just easily go in because this is
mainly just a bathroom underneath i have
my storage and crates
i use these crates a lot they're all
standardized
and then
one of the things i did for the bat is
that it can take out all my stuff
and this thing goes up
like this
so then i can store
big sheets of plywood in case we need to
move material around
so one thing i also use a lot in the van
is magnets so for instance uh to hang
stuff like anything is metal even a
screw
also that's kita that's
you can move this chair around
so you can
drive make it a bit more spacious inside
which has been quite nice
and in here this little table
which i use for working
that's pretty basic
and then with my laptop i can work here
plug it in the usb charger and i can be
here for hours and hours
yeah so one of the recent problems we
have in the van
especially being parked in a longer
period of time is that i had a mouse
inside
so first i heard it walking around at
the dashboard which was a bit annoying
because it eats cables and stuff and it
makes noise starts to smell and recently
i also saw sat here walking on the
ceiling so between the roof and
the metal roof and the ceiling you see
the mouse taps at night
i've been trying many things to get it
out open up the whole dashboard but
it's been bugging me for quite a bit the
van itself is a
mercedes-609d
it's originally from the german army
served as an ambulance so there were
hospital bats and stuff in the back
it's from 1989 so around 30 years old
and yeah that's it i actually also made
a video before about the whole
conversion of this thing so you could
see it starting from a german argentine
to this
so we're now on top of the van and
here's the solar panel
i forgot the white heads i think like
280 or something but it's enough to get
the whole thing going
and also a big roof rack here also used
to transport materials i can put six
meter beams on top which is a bit
standard in metal
so this we've actually been using a lot
to transport things
view is great can see a lot
all right so that was it from my then
thank you for watching and
also a window
and this is rita's van
hi
welcome to the
german post van and the place where i
kinda live
[Music]
this is a cool magnetic curtain
very very very crucial and sometimes of
the year not just for mosquitoes for any
kind of flying animals
and this is the van where i have most of
my things
where i
sleep
and where i
run away from busy times
in the camp
[Music]
we have a few features
of the van which are super cool
because it makes the van as you see
there is no bed and it makes the van
quite versatile as a room or as an
office
or as an other place
there is a desk a place just to keep
stuff
a closet
yeah and just like cool feature is just
this pad that you can actually fold or
unfold
so the van you can just
clutch it
on the top
very versatile space
super nice
and when we are done with sleeping
just easily putting back
so this is a super nice simple feature
with a hose attached to the wall
and attached to a water container and
then just with a small air pump that we
just press
we have some water directed into the
basin
maybe some of you saw in a
previous video that in winter it might
froze so there is no water coming
so this place is also
very useful to be used as an office so
you can just fold the bed and put your
chair here and just work
a bit a bit without being in the center
of the community
because we don't have enough of project
camp
we put
a map here on the wall but actually it's
just that we have an outer perspective
of the land and we can go a bit more
into the thinking of different zones of
project camp
but that is coming soon
here on the back
it's where the solar panel lays
it's a super cool clever system that
matia set up
because it comes with a cord so it means
that you can actually detach the solar
panel from the van and you can just
place it in the sand while you can park
the van in the shade so it's really
really cool
there is another cool feature of this
van but you can't really see it now
because it's more a night feature which
is the lights of the van
this one
was from mattia the italian guy that
maybe some of you guys already remember
from previous videos
he had this van and he also renewed a
lot and built a lot of this van and the
van was in a state that it couldn't be
on the road anymore so mattia decided to
leave the van to slowly die here on the
camp it was a super cool gift for us the
life in the camp can easily become quite
intense
as there is a lot of people and
just there is not many like closed
spaces where you can be a bit more
chilled
so with this van it serves a bit like a
refuge
where you can just come and be a bit
more isolated
i hope you guys enjoy it thank you again
to matia and
ciao
[Music]
ok you have seen the events but also we
have people living in tents in our camp
welcome to downtown
[Music]
yeah living in a tent is pretty nice
just sleeping here and can live the rest
of the day out in the common areas so
it's not so bad so far it's really nice
now it starts to rain and we see
how it goes and yeah feels good it's
good because
it's really
small
and i feel like it's warmer
[Music]
simple and i
can
bring my stuff here and i don't need to
bring a big van and i can travel in the
bus
i can hear the raindrops on the top
canvas
it sort of has this sound of fingers on
a drum
everything's simple not much to clean
and
yeah
it's good
somewhere we have a couple of
of parties around from the neighbors but
normally super quiet and you can hear
the crickets stuff like that i don't
know i like to have my little cozy
corner that
doesn't require me to drive or use
any
gas
it's not that warm
actually these big canvas tents seem
like they're colder than like a small
normal camping tent
uh you can't stand up
always sitting down
maybe having a better mattress in the
future could be an upgrade
it's almost more space than i know what
to do with i've been i've been living
out of my backpack for for two months
now and
i don't have that many things so there's
only
so much space i can take up most of my
time is still empty
because it is small you cannot do
everything here so i just use it to rest
so i can only be sitting down i don't
have the
electricity connection here
but
yeah that's it's the it can also get wet
in the rain
[Music]
before i came here i was sleeping in a
hammock under
a rain tarp for a month and a half so
this is definitely an upgrade
you can go more
into nature than when you are in a van
so you can hear the sound you can feel
the the rain the sun coming
maybe some insects walking around two
nights ago i heard some animal or
something scratching around outside then
i lay in bed and i wonder what it is
yeah i always be close to my 10 in the
ensuite just over here
one thing that's worried me
is that this big tree
is almost about to fall on top of the
tent this is the challenge we have with
this tent
so this is how we live here in camp we
spend most of our time outside working
doing stuff and getting together
we have shared facilities so our vans
and tents are just the place where we go
to rest
at least until our sketchy ruin is
finished then we will have a better
setup for guests and for winter time
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update
oh and support us on patreon if you can
you